[Music]
welcome to another episode of theater
journeys i'm bruno aziza and i'm excited
to be here today with bob from geotab
and so we're going to learn from him
about his journey and the amazing growth
and success he's had and he's also going
to share with us his do's and his don'ts
bob thank you so much for taking the
time to talk to us today before we get
started tell us a little bit about
geotab hey bruno no problem uh yeah so
geotab is a world leader in the
telematics space and so really what that
means is we have millions of connected
vehicles in fact we have over two
million connected vehicles driving
around with our little device inside of
them around the world and really really
dense population of vehicles here in
north america and the large population
in europe latin america and geotag has
been expanding pretty rapidly over the
past few years and so it gives us a
really really unique look at the world
we live in from a data perspective
because this data is immensely useful
for fleet managers so they're using it
to manage where their vehicles go and
company operations but on aggregate
these two million vehicles can tell us
what the temperature is on the side of
the road and whether a road is bumpy in
the middle of europe or in the middle of
the united states and we can learn an
awful lot about cities around us and
whether intersections take longer at
certain times of the day and what
traffic patterns look like and so you
know over the past five years that i've
been at geotab we've gone from about 400
000 of these connected devices to
somewhere in the 2.2 million uh
neighborhood today and so that kind of
growth has been both amazing and a
challenge for us and now the data that
you collect of course is 24 7
it's real time you know tell us a little
about the the volume there yeah the data
we collect you're right is real time and
24 7. customers of geotab range from
small mom and pop
trucking companies to emergency services
so the data needs to be correct and
timely and so we're streaming this data
in every single day from a data
analytics perspective that means about
40 billion points of data that we get to
play with every single day and i think
we're somewhere in the neighborhood of
11 petabytes of data sitting in google
bigquery which is our data warehouse of
choice so we're definitely talking about
large data set fast moving data set the
products involved geo we're talking
about bigquery data flow real time data
cloud composer tell us a little bit
about the use cases specifically that
you're using these products for sure so
our customers are monitoring their
fleets
their own fleets looking at their own
operations but as a whole if we can take
these 2.1 million vehicles and we can
take this data that's coming in at that
pace and we can actually run analytics
on that there's a lot we can learn and
teach our customers about their data so
one of the use cases that comes to mind
is we had a customers that were telling
us that battery breakdowns were a big
problem and so we have fleets that are
one vehicle but we also have fleets that
might be a hundred thousand vehicles and
so if you scale up roadside breakdowns
the batteries themselves aren't very
expensive but when you're saying 80 of
our on-road breakdowns happen because of
electrical systems it's not the battery
it's not the part it's the sending of a
tow truck it's the toe it's the sending
of a mechanic and the replacing of these
parts that become very very expensive
and so we started a plc one of one of
the things that i really believe in is
getting customers involved first so we
can really truly understand the customer
problem and so we thought okay
this particular customer has a large
fleet but in the in the 2.1 million
vehicles there's tens of thousands of
other vehicles that drive and operate in
similar conditions with similar engine
types what can we learn from the group
that we can then help this customer
identify batteries that potentially
could fail and so we did a four month
poc with a very very large fleet and the
goal was to reduce these roadside
breakdowns they're expensive product
doesn't get to the door slas are broken
and i think you know there were some
learnings here as well i mean i think
our goal on the onset was oh it's a
predictive maintenance problem everybody
talks about mean time to fail we need to
tell this customer within three days
your battery's going to fail and what we
learned through the short plc was that
that really wasn't what we needed to do
what we needed to do was help this
customer with so many vehicles
understand which of their vehicles are
exhibiting electrical systems issues and
which of their vehicles appear to have
bad batteries or or don't look normal as
it compares to the rest of the 2.1
million million vehicles that operate
like they do and so it was a pretty
successful little poc that has now spun
into into a core product that we can
offer to customers in that we were able
to reduce their downtime by you know
almost 20 25 of the roadside downtime
was reduced and there was a you know
little side effects that we didn't
expect we had 10 percent almost ten
percent of less labor cost because there
weren't so many surprise battery
replacements or electrical assistance
tests on the side of the road so it was
a great little plc of course then the
problem becomes how do you scale from
one customer to many customers and i
think because we use google bigquery in
some of those tools as our core data
warehouse and because that's where we
run a lot of our experiments the scaling
issue
becomes non-existent for us as we as we
scale up and and we just kind of lean in
on some of that capacity that is offered
to us by some of those products and you
have been able to scale it as you know
as much innovation as as you put out
here actually i think you you have about
eight patents
uh on this particular uh use case set up
as an outcome yeah there's about eight
patents on that particular use case
right now as an outcome and uh you know
we're able to scale this up and
generalize uh the solution and you know
we'll be rolling out live with it
actually took us about a year um you
know what makes us unique as well as a
company is since we manufacture the
hardware we're able to push out updates
so it became a real team effort at
geotab in that we actually discovered
new novel ways of recording some of this
information and detecting changes to
make the product even better so it was a
bit of an iterative process with the uh
the whole engineering side of the
company to get this out there but yeah
scale hasn't scale has never been the
problem you know ingesting the data
hasn't been a problem and running
queries over the data and models over
the data hasn't been the problem uh
which really frees us up then to work
hand-in-hand with customers and really
focusing on on what the the actual
mechanical problem is so that's quite an
amazing journey starting with one
customer and then expanding that to the
rest of your fleet and understanding
this a million data points at a time and
with the outcome with an amazing
recognition for your innovation what
have you learned through the process
here what are some of the do's and
don'ts here maybe let's start with the
positive first what are some of the
things that are the dues that everybody
here listening to us should go out and
do i think you know the one one thing
that taught us an awful lot and it had
kind of a waterfall effect in lessons
was engaging with customers early in the
process you know the first few years
i've been with geotab for about five
years and the data team was quite small
at the time and we've grown rapidly and
those first few years we're really
learning and exploring and playing with
the data and with customers to to
understand the value that we could then
derive out of it in the years to come
and so working with customers closely
and early allowed us to start conducting
research with a clear path to product so
we weren't conducting research for the
sake of research but with a clear path
like an applied research approach where
we the outcome should solve a business
problem and you know really the the
object was to fail fast the the four
month plc wasn't you know was with one
of many four-month plc's and those other
ones you know if we fail fast and pivot
uh we can get to a solution a little bit
quicker i think one of the biggest
learnings for any of us engineers we
wanted to make these 99 like i said
meantime to feel 99 accurate models
when at the end of the day we're saving
real money and and saving real downtime
for customers without needing to be 99
accurate so i think it was a lesson
learned there that 99 accurate on a
problem that nobody wants you to solve
it's not a good approach it's better to
be reasonably accurate on a large scale
problem that can really help folks and
and then iterate on that problem and
bring up that accuracy yeah it's the
idea around being directionally right
and then improving on that results
rather than just trying to be right uh
and imperfect rather than be done what
about the the opposite of that what are
some of the mistakes
that you think people listening to us
should look out for and try to avoid
even though they you know they are the
result of things that might have been
common sense in the first place i've
said this before i think i think i've
said it at some of your offices i'm
doing a small talk one of the best
things about say a product like google
bigquery is that it's very very easy to
get your data into google bigquery and
move it around and one of the worst
things about google bigquery is that
it's very very easy to get your data
into your query and one of the things
that geotech did early on was we started
pushing as much data as we could into
google bigquery so it's not just the
vehicle data it's it's operational data
it's all of our server metrics
application logs that really really
helps us triage a problem from beginning
to end so definitely would not change
how we did that but in doing so you know
you can't lag data governance and data
ops far behind because
you end up with multiple sources of
ground truth or disparate data sets that
are trying to answer the same problem
and so i think with that ease of use and
ease of getting data into bigquery came
some hiccups along the way where you
know we need to now clean up some of
those resources and we need to figure
out which of a and b is ground truth to
solve this problem so those data silos
can can happen pretty quickly yeah and
they can cost you a lot down the line
did you have to hire different types of
folks to make sure that you'd manage for
that or how did you built it into the
process
yeah over time i think we started out
heavy on the science and analyst side of
things because the demand we have so
many managed services that we leverage
from you guys but over time uh we
started to pick up many many more data
engineers and folks that are focused on
pipelines and best practices
data governance and data operations so
so yeah i think there was a fundamental
shift there what was amazing about it as
i said those first few years that i
spent anyways at geotab were a lot of
experimentation a lot of playing and we
didn't have to worry about the overhead
of pipelines and things like that but
now as things become mature in products
we need to make sure that those
pipelines run that there's monitoring
and slas and all of those fun things and
and i think that we've played catch up a
little bit there that's outstanding bob
thank you so much for sharing these
lessons with us today you know i learned
a lot about
building data products means engaging
with customers early and in your case
you learn from one customer and scaled
it to the rest of them so it's really
quite amazing
eight patents an incredible story there
and then the don't is don't wait to
implement data ops and data governance
early uh maybe through data engineers
that you might want to hire or a change
in your process so you can avoid did a
silos because they could cost you a lot
throughout the journey again like i said
thanks for giving us the time today i
hope many people are going to reach out
to you and connect with you they've got
a lot to learn from geotab we appreciate
your time and we appreciate you being a
great partner of ours we'll talk to you
soon no problem thanks bruno
[Music]